las calles de Brasil lloran por Pelé
edificios de la avenida paulista en Sao
Paulo rindieron homenaje al Astro que
falleció este jueves
grafitis pantallas callejeras y un
icónico edificio de la ciudad Se
iluminaron con su imagen y la leyenda
Gracias Rey mientras que en Río de
Janeiro el maracaná encendió luces
doradas y el Cristo Redentor se tiñó de
colores para no sol embral no es solo
para recordar la estrella que fue y que
Ahora descansa allá arriba sino también
para honrar al pueblo brasileño
recordando Todas Las alegrías que ha
dado
la pérdida de pelota descendió las
fronteras el mítico wembley de Londres
despidió al brasileño con un cartel e
iluminado de amarillo y verde en tanto
que decenas de fanáticos se reunieron a
homenajearla en el Times Square de Nueva
York
en Australia un partido la primera
división de este viernes abrió los
homenajes en los estadios de fútbol que
sucederán durante el fin de semana
mientras que en África los periódicos
entraron sus portadas en Pelé y los
ciudadanos lamentaron su partida
pelea más grande que el propio fútbol
era como un líder mundial porque de niño
dio Esperanza empezó a jugar al fútbol
sin botines y luego llevó a Brasil a la
copa del mundo
nunca dejó de representar a su país su
gente y a la raza negra es una leyenda
fenomenal
el estadio de Santos donde Pelé forjó su
leyenda apagó sus luces y solo dejó la
imagen de una corona en la pantalla de
Vila belmiro por su parte la Fifa en su
sede en Suiza hizo a media hasta todas
las banderas en honor al único jugador
que levantó tres veces la copa del mundo